good to be back good to be back at Yale
and in this course once again on this
really important topic and I'll assume
that nothing much has changed and the
ethos of Yale students in the ten years
since I read a lot quite ten years since
I retired so you're still feisty and
you'll have disagreements so the
description for today's seminar that I
was sent opposes two quite different
though related questions one is this do
religious people have good reasons to
support pluralistic democracy or to
quote the precise words of the
description how can we encourage
adherents of exclusive faith traditions
to affirm the political project of
Liberal Democratic democracy and the
other question that I that was in the
description I got was this what is the
role of religious reasons in public
political debate within a pluralistic
democracy or in the precise words of the
description for what reasons and under
what conditions should democratic
citizens appeal to matters of religious
faith in public discourse
I trust you see as I saw the difference
between those two questions
the first asks whether religious people
have good reasons to support a certain
kind of political structure namely
pluralist liberal democracy the second
assumes the existence of a religiously
pluralistic democracy and it asks what
should be the role of religious reasons
within such a democracy in public debate
about political issues both of those
support for of the structure and reasons
for political debate within the
structure are important both are huge
the sensible thing for me would be to
choose one of the two and talk only
about it but I've chosen today not to be
sensible and to say something about each
of them here goes in the order of
mentioned what I say on the first is
going to overlap interestingly with some
things Miroslav said and we did not
coordinate
this so start with the first a little
bit of really quick risk history liberal
or pluralistic democracy emerged in the
West out of the breakdown of Christendom
and what was Christendom
well Christendom assumed a religiously
unified society specifically it assumed
a society in which everybody was
Christian in which everybody was
baptized of course
parenthesis everybody knew that here and
there within Europe there were people
who were not baptized in particular Jews
not only but in particular but the
theory did not take account of their
presence with the result as you know
that the position of Jews was not only
theoretically anomalous but often
politically precarious they had no clear
position in the structure unlike the
militant Islam now given a society of
Christians the basic idea of Christendom
was this that this religiously unified
society that's a crucial part of it that
this religiously unified society had two
rules as if they were standardly called
two rules two governances both being
manifestations of God's rule one rule
was that of the church and one rule was
that of the Empire and since both were
over the same people the differentiation
between these two rules could not be by
reference to the subjects but had to be
by reference to the aspects of people's
lives that these two rules governed
right so one people but two rules over
different aspects of their lives
so it was a division of powers rather
than a division of subjects often it was
said that the church ruled over the
spiritual life of the people and that
the Empire ruled over the secular life
of the people the latter at the Empire
rules over the secular life was by no
means interpreted to mean that the
Empire stayed out of moral and religious
matters
it was on the contrary to the best of my
knowledge universally agreed that it was
the duty of the Emperor the ruler to
cultivate morality and true religion in
the people and not just the cultivate to
enforce now as you would guess there
were all kinds of hassles over what sec
over what this spiritual secular
division came from so Western
Christendom was filled with hassles on
that score and by and large they were
settled less by theoretical acuity than
by who had the appropriate power so you
got the picture or religious religiously
unified people under these two rules and
I think it was pretty clearly the
breakup of the Western Church oh the
Eastern Eastern Europe
I'd have to say different things about
it sorry okay so it was the breakup of
the Western Church in the 1500s that
eventually caused the collapse of
Christendom and forced Europe to rethink
its political structure and the relation
between that and religion at first it
experimented with with little christen
domes many Christian guns Germany would
be a Lutheran Christian Spain would
continue to be a Catholic Christendom
Switzerland would be a reformed
Christendom Scotland would be a
Presbyterian Christendom England would
be an Anglican Christendom and so forth
but very soon religious diversity got
inside of all these many Christian domes
and that idea Christendom became
impossible both maxie and many forms
became impossible as a political
structure well to take enormous leaps
after centuries of confusion ferment and
bloodshed there eventually emerged
towards the end of the 1700s the
American experiment of liberal
pluralistic democracy now
a lot of stuff in between but so it's
not just out of the blue it was I think
we tend to forget a radical and a risky
experiment much about it had never been
tried before and in particular nothing
like the relation between religion and
the state that the constitutional
founders proposed had ever been tried
before so here's the central question
and what was the new proposed relation
between the religions of the people and
the state the American state I think we
can probably summarize it in the
following four structural principles
first church and state are to be
distinct institutions synagogue in the
state mosque and state you get the point
there's to be a distinction a clear
distinction between ecclesiastical
religious institutions and the state of
course as I've just observed there had
long been such a distinction in the West
so this was not an innovation on the
part of the American founders they were
carrying on what they know from their
Western antecedents a clear
institutional distinction between church
and state second yeah that was the first
second second important structural
principle was freedom of religious
exercise the state is to not govern how
people exercise their religion third the
state
when distributing benefits and burdens
is not to differentiate in its treatment
of citizens on account of their religion
or lack thereof let me say it again the
state and its distribution of benefits
and burdens whatever is not to
discriminate among its citizens on the
basis of their religion or lack thereof
it's going to discriminate on some other
basis but it's not to discriminate on
that basis and here's the fourth
principle fourth there is to be no
differentiation among citizens in their
right to hold office in the state and in
their right to to political voice in the
conduct and the personnel of the state
no discrimination among people on the
basis of their religion as to whether
you can hold office or honor whether
you've got on whether you've got voice
and electing people for positions in the
state what do you think I think those
four principles structural principles
about the relation and religion in the
state are essential to the very idea of
a liberal or pluralistic democracy you
can have a democracy in the absence of
those four principles in the sense that
you can have people voting for positions
on the regime and so forth like you
don't have a liberal pluralistic
democracy
okay let's not and this gets to Mears
last point
let's not conceal from ourselves the
fact that acceptance of those four
principles requires a lot of equalities
requires a lot of shaping up on the part
of both the state and the religions
present in society each party the state
and the religions have to refrain from
doing a lot of what they have
historically done now fortunately at the
time of the American Founding most of
the shaping of had already occurred or
was about to occur in the u.s. with
respect to the state and the religious
people were beginning to think along
these lines or nobody had a forcing them
to thinking along these lines but to
repeat it was historically a radical and
risky experiment a state with no
official religion a state with no
official religion and any way had never
seriously been tried before now we're
all aware of the fact that many
religious people around the globe do not
like this kind of democracy and I dare
say that many of you probably most of
you are aware that some of those people
are located in this country that is in
the United States u.s. is not this
country for all of you here I'm sure
that is to say let me put it more
bluntly there are a lot of present-day
American Christians who do not like
liberal democracy that phase of it that
I described that was clear from the
Howard was quotation a good many
Christian leaders including some
theologians what have what I can only
think it was an extremely sour attitude
towards liberal democracy
no number of reasons for that as you'd
expect but if I hear correctly there's
one common theme running through those
in this country and abroad and that
theme is this once upon a time the state
was the highest expression or one of the
two highest expressions of the religio
moral unity of the people here's where
their religious more unity came to its
topmost institutional expression a
liberal democratic society is committed
to its not being that there is it's not
giving expression to any one particular
religious party it's committed to being
no more than an arrangement of
convenience so it's in whereby a number
of such distinct communities can live
together but it itself is aa
religious it's aa more an arrangement of
convenience for such communities and
okay here's the real point and thereby
it forces a dichotomy into the lives of
religious people it forces them to
divorce their religion from their
politics the Muslims who live in this
country cannot live by Sharia they can't
and you can fill out the counterparts
for any other religion you want one of
the most influential twentieth century
Muslim writers I'm going to mispronounce
his name I'm sure so you can tap those
of you who know how to pronounce it will
tell me afterwards Saeed Putin an
Egyptian intellectual who was executed
by the Egyptian government in 1966
kocha had lived for a time in the u.s.
out in Colorado and it found American
life abhorrent and the lives of America
there is what he called marvelous race a
hideous schizophrenia
a hideous schizophrenia between religion
and life and he thought this hideous
schizophrenia had its origins in
original Christianity where he thought
that Jesus had spiritual eyes Jewish
religion and he thought that liberal
democracy by his very structure
expressed and reinforced this hideous
schizophrenia it forces the
privatization of religion and if the
four principles that I cited are indeed
basic structural principles of liberal
democracy then in a structural sort of
way he's right about that that kind of
shaping up of religion is required by
the very structure of a liberal
democracy so pull it together like this
if religious people have good reasons
for supporting liberal pluralistic
democracy those reasons will have to
support those four principles and the
kind of division that I mentioned now I
think that some religious people do have
good reasons for supporting those four
principles to speak for myself
I think Christianity provides such
reasons though there are a lot of my
fellow Christians who disagree now I
said I was going to talk about both
questions but I've really almost eaten
up my time so what do you think Miroslav
sure I just cut off what I have to say
about religious reasons and liberal
democracy ok ok so now the second
question so my citation of those four
principles may well have left you
thinking as it did kutol that there just
isn't any place for religious reasons
and public debate in a democracy you may
have concluded that the principles those
four principles rule of
and quite a few writers in recent years
have made that inference at the very
idea of a liberal democracy rules out
the use of religious reasons in public
debate but I think that's a mistake the
government in the ways I mentioned has
to be impartial in ass treatment of
citizens with respect to their religion
or lack thereof I think that does not
imply excluding religious reasons it
excludes thinking religiously about
political topics and speaking of now
when you're reading for today there are
some pieces that introduce you to that
debate that's been going on for two
decades whatever so you know the basic
issues I'm not going to dabble into all
of them but I think it may be helpful to
bring these two topics together if I
briefly review why John Rawls thought it
was one of the principles of liberal
democracy that the citizens should use
what he calls public reason and not
religious reasons in public debate so
this is sort of tie the two together
okay Rawls I talked about a structural
features for the structural features of
a liberal democracy Rawls Rawls was of
the view and I share this view Rose was
of the view that behind these structural
principles there's a certain cluster of
ideas about how citizens are to treat
each other and that the structure is an
expression of these background implicit
ideas as to how we should treat each
other these background ideas make sense
of the structure contrast of
happenstance and Rawls thought then
obviously that citizens who really
believed in liberal democracy as opposed
to just putting up with it implicitly
accept these background explanatory
principles I don't have them at the top
of their heads it's implicit but they're
implicitly accepting it if they agree
with liberal democracy instead
just putting up with it here's one of
those important implicit background
principles Rawls thought we are to treat
each other as free and equal fundamental
explanatory background principle to
treat citizens are to treat each other
as free and equal okay so now says Rawls
ask yourself this question what does
that principle treating each other is
free and equal what does that principle
imply for how we debate and decide
political issues what is the free and
equal principle imply for how we conduct
our debates and here's Rawls answer at
least when it comes to important issues
of justice we should stand ready to
appeal to principles that we can expect
all of our fellow citizens to share or
at least all who sincerely believe in
liberal democracy the others may not
sure we should appeal the principles
that we can expect all the believers are
fellow believers in liberal democracy to
share otherwise here's wallet if we just
go ahead and vote our own view we're
imposing our views on the others and not
treating them as equal I'm saying I know
better than you what the laws of this
land should be like I'm not treating you
as a co-author of the laws that should
be obvious at a glance that that
principle eliminates the use of
religious reasons because you one thing
you can be absolutely sure of any
religious reason that you can devise is
not going to be shared by some of your
present they fellow Americans right okay
so where do we find the shared reasons
and Rawls is ingenious I think of it as
a bootstrapping suggestion Rawls is
ingenious suggestion wizard here's where
you can find the principles
look back once again at those principles
implicit in liberal democracy that we
got this first one from treating
everybody is free and equal look back
the other implicit principles everybody
who accepts liberal democracy believes
those rights so that's going to be our
body of our shared principles that's
what he called public reason it's gonna
take some work
to dig them out their implicit that's
what political philosophers are for so
forth but that's what we should appeal
to it won't matter since Rawls of people
if religious people add on some
religious reasons it's okay
and it won't matter if we're debating
minor matters my memory of New Haven is
that always by Thanksgiving there was a
great big tree Christmas tree on the
green and there's not this year so my
New Haven must have had a dispute about
that and Rawls would say they don't have
to avoid using religious reasons to
settle I mean it's not like well
somebody might huh ah very all right
that's what I expect so let me talk to a
conclusion I'm not gonna rehearse my
reasons for thinking that this proposal
and genius and interesting as it is
doesn't work it's my impression that the
state of the debate over this now is
that it's widely agreed that those
opposed to using religious reasons and
public debate have not succeeded in
making their case so here's my own view
briefly presented with two crucial
implications sorry two crucial
qualifications my view is this I think
it's okay for citizens to use whatever
reasons but they themselves have for
their political views or whatever
reasons they find cogent rarely if ever
does it happen that consensus emerges so
I think a crucial part of liberal
democracy is a fair vote and I find it's
endlessly curious that Rawls
allottee and larmor and so forth Harbor
must say almost nothing about vote I
think we never achieve consensus so we
have to have a fair vote here are the
two qualifications the entire debate
takes place within the framework of a
constitution some proposals are just off
the table or they're so hard to get onto
the table that they may just as well be
off the table that's our great that's
the great protection in a liberal
democracy against the rule the
oppressive rule of the majority there's
a constitution which says these things
can't be done
second I've come to think that the
character of the debate is important how
the debate is conducted not so much as
content but how its conducted citizens
are to treat each other civilly become
informed be willing to present their
reasons to others be willing to listen
to the reasons of others and let me just
say parenthetically that one of my great
what we're doing I want sorrow is
laments whatever is that American
political dialogue is so uncivil it is
so chock-full of people demeaning their
fellow citizens whatever be their
reasons I should never mean their fellow
citizens
so I think the debate over whether
religious reasons are acceptable was an
important debate to have but I think the
real discussion now has to be over and
how should we conduct that debate so
that we treat our fellow citizens with
dignity and honor and justice and
respect